And everybody, it's Dr. Kevin Cutters, welcome to another video on our course, the Three
Faces of Lime.
This one's, how do I know if I'm infected and what in the world am I supposed to do?
So let's talk about this.
So when you have a tick bite, sometimes you'd ever find the tick, right?
And you just have the sore, you have this inflamed area, that's difficult.
But let's talk about if you do find the tick.
So you have a tick on, you take the tick off, you have to know how to identify these ticks.
So I live in Minnesota, Wisconsin area and we just have learned to identify the difference
between a deer tick and a wood tick.
So wood tick, which is the American dog tick, we call a wood tick, in our area that we live
doesn't really cause any disease process, it's not really spreading any pathogens.
Now this wood tick in the Rocky Mountains can cause disease and we'll talk about that
in a second.
The deer tick is what we're concerned about here in this area, though there's argument
that deer, that wood ticks can also spread lime.
It's possible that you could get lime from a wood tick, anything's possible these days.
And it's very difficult to look at the small nibs of this.
How do you tell these things apart for quite a long, the smallest nib on both the deer tick
and the wood tick are hard to identify.
First of all, they're hard to see.
The first time I got lime disease, I had a little sore and it was a perfect bullseye reaction
or all that spot.
And in that spot, there was a little teeny fleck that I thought was like a piece of black
pepper to the naked eye.
I could not see that it wasn't organism, but I took it off and I saved it in a piece of
tape and I looked at it underneath a magnified glass and it was a deer tick nib.
Well, all I could identify at that point in time was a tick nib.
It was a teeny little, I could not see the legs of it at all until I looked at it under
a magnified lens.
But I had a perfect bullseye reaction, not everybody gets a perfect bullseye reaction, nobody
gets it, even a reaction whatsoever, they don't know that they have chronic lime until
years later, they never identify this in phase one.
But for those who do and are able to get the tick that bit them, you need to know how
to identify it.
So downloading pictures like this off the internet, that's just where I got this picture is going
to be your best way to search for what that tick is.
And then just because it is a deer tick doesn't mean that you have lime.
So it doesn't mean that it is infected with lime and we'll talk about that in a little
bit too.
So these ticks can spread different disease, even the regular wood tick can spread all sorts
of disease as well.
So it's just something we need to be aware of and be spotting depending on what area in
the country that you live.
Now there's five cardinal signs according to physiology books of infection.
So the five cardinal signs are redness, heat, warmth, swelling, pain and loss of function.
This is what we learned in medical schools and in carpractic schools in naturopathic schools.
These five cardinal signs of some sort of infection.
There's a nice little graphic that very well did.
It's pain, and heat, and redness, and swelling and again some people have a diagnosis of chronic
life and they don't ever remember this phase.
They never remember going through this phase.
So remember also if you didn't find the tick and you have these things, but you live in
ticked country and we're in ticked season, it still does not mean that you have live
already.
The co-infections you could have gotten a fly bite.
You could have gotten a infection from a mosquito bite.
You could have gotten a spider bite.
This is where it gets very difficult.
How am I supposed to know what I have going on?
It is very difficult.
Let's walk through some of the thought processes here.
So first of all, if you have a tick that you can save, you want to save the tick to identify
it.
If you don't have the tick to save or you did, you still want to think about treating the
site topically.
And then thirdly, you want to treat your body systemically.
So and then fourthly, if you need to seek medical help, it's always wise to seek medical
help.
This course is not supposed to be a substitute for medical help, but let's talk about this.
If you have the ability to save it to identify, put it on a piece of tape so that you can
look at it under a microscope or magnifying lens like I had to do it or bring it in for identification
if you can't figure out what it is.
There are two known pictures in the internet.
If you have the ability to get it tested locally, depending on what part of the country that you're
in, if you're out in the, you know, not near any metropolitan area where testing is available
that must this might not be available for you to do, but we've had people that have got the
tick tested to see if it was infected with any disease.
There's some benefit to getting that done too.
But you wouldn't wait until you find out the test results to start treating yourself.
Or would you wait to find out the test results before you'd also dig in to investigate what's
going on with you?
Because if you have symptoms that you need to treat, typically because boy, I have this inflamed
area, I have this raised area on my skin, it's sore, it's itchy, is it red?
Yes, it's red.
Is it inflamed?
Yes, it's raised.
You know, these are signs of infection.
So think about treating it topically.
You could use different essential oils on it, typically.
You could use over-the-counter triple antibiotic or an over-the-counter topical antiseptic.
You're trying to kill a bacteria.
So using something like that makes sense.
So a lot of people have done very well by using different essential oils, a regular oil
and frankincense and different things on it, and have treated their local infection very
well.
So think about doing some things like that.
There's some different comfrey sams and clangela oils and different things that you can use
to treat it topically.
We'll have more information on this in other places in these modules.
And then you have to treat yourself systemically.
Think about taking different immune system stimulants.
That's why I created that Acute LX is because it's an immune system stimulant in the case
of a known infection.
You could use Acute LX if I think I have an Acute infection of a stomach bug or a bad cold
or, you know, COVID or, you know, anything like that.
But certainly when you have any type of infection, you want your immune system to ramp up and
kill that pathogen.
So remember what I've talked about.
Your immune system does one thing and it doesn't well.
It kills things.
That's what your immune system does.
It doesn't escort things out of the body.
It doesn't go make friends with things.
Your immune system is created to kill pathogens.
So you want to stimulate a healthy immune response if you think that you have a possibility
of a pathogen.
So pathogens are things that enter your body, bacteria, viruses, molds, fungi that are not
supposed to be there.
Living organisms that your immune system is going to kill.
So a pathogen is a living organism that is trying to come into your body and to replicate.
You use it as a host for it to be able to make lots of babies and build a home.
You don't want it there.
So our immune system is meant to kill it.
So anything you can do to stimulate an immune response, medicinal mushrooms, elderberry,
echinacea, things like that, the vitamin C that are going to be good, TH1 immune system
stimulants.
That's what you want to pump into your system in the case of a possible acute infection.
And then seek medical help.
So if you do have Lyme, Lyme is categorized as Borrelia, Burgodorfia, bacterial infection.
So a bacterial infection, yes, your immune system can kill it.
You should stimulate it with immune body systemic immune system stimulation like we just talked
about.
But it doesn't mean that we shouldn't not use antibiotics and I'll use myself as an example.
I was so, so sick, I do that something was going on.
I needed to take an antibiotic.
And I figured out that it was Lyme disease and by taking it antibiotic, it just knocked
it on me right away.
The first time I had Lyme, I described in this video, I got the Bullseye reaction, the second
time I had Lyme, I had no bite size.
I did not see any bite, any tick.
I could not find any rash on my body.
I could not find any bite site.
It was early in March in northern Minnesota, kind of before the ticks were out.
I could not think it for the life of me that I had Lyme disease.
But because I had Lyme disease prior, but literally probably 10 years prior, that was the last
time I got that utter sickness except when we were missionaries down the Mexico and I had
we ate an out down there and had contaminated goat, that's a different story.
So that was the level of sickness that I had.
I knew I had some sort of crazy infection.
I first thought I had some sort of food board infection, but I had anything differently.
It just didn't fit and I thought, oh my gosh, it's Lyme disease.
It literally took an antibiotic and I felt almost 80% better after just one antibiotic.
I think I didn't follow the course because I'm so against really my gut, but that's just
me.
I'm suggesting you follow your medical doctor's advice.
But I ended up taking antibiotics for three or four days, knocked it out of me completely
and I was just fine, but I was just deathly sick.
So I am very much in favor, probably because of my experience of getting medical help and
getting an antibiotic.
The problem with this is, and I hear this over and over again, as I went to my medical doctor
and he wants to do a Lyme test on me and so he did a blood test on me and I'll get it
back in three days to find out if I have Lyme and if I don't have Lyme, he's not going
to give me an antibiotic, but if I do, then he'll give me an antibiotic.
Okay, you doctor, I'm sorry, I disagree with your doctor.
I was going to say something nasty, but I won't.
You need to find another doctor, go somewhere else because if the doctor do beans about
taking care of people, he wouldn't rely solely on a test.
He would rely or she would rely on clinical experience in that, oh my gosh, here you live
in an area with Lyme disease.
You have all the symptoms of Lyme, of acute Lyme or acute vector board infection.
By all means, we're going to give you an antibiotic and give you instructions, something like,
you're going to take this for 20 days or whatever, he's going to give you a doxocyclet or maybe
10 days of a moxicillin and then, but if it does not make you feel better very soon within
the first couple of days, I want to see you again.
Maybe the Marcus Wellby MDs are no longer exist, but you need to find one, I think they're
out there.
Find a Lyme letter doctor that's willing to give you, so willing to treat you based upon your
symptom pattern, based upon what you're presenting clinically, not some trained technician
that can't do anything, his or her hands are tied because of their own ignorance or because
of what their clinical protocol states.
The reason why I say that is because you could either become a, deathly ill by the time
your test comes back or b, your test show a false negative because it's not necessarily
in your blood anymore, it's in your tissue so that little vial of blood that they draw
out of your vein doesn't contain enough bacteria to show a positive test so you can get a false
negative.
All the time and then you go, oh, I don't have Lyme disease, but you're getting sicker
and sicker and sicker and it moves into chronic Lyme and you have your life destroyed because
some doctor is a bozo, so I don't care if I get in trouble, this video, it's too important,
people's lives are in danger here, if you can't be a doctor and treat a person clinically,
you shouldn't be a doctor, won't you just become a technician in some place?
Um, it's just sorry, okay, back to this, so I'm very much in favor of treating yourself,
yes, I know, I'm an alternative practitioner, antibiotics, tear up your gut, and screw up your
flora, you have to help rebuild your whole gut flora, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, I get it,
but would you rather take a couple days of antibiotics and knock this thing out and then deal with
healing your gut back? If you take an antibiotic and it doesn't help and you're on it for five,
six, seven days and you're still getting sicker and sicker, it's probably not a bacterial infection,
people, come on, work with me here, so an antibiotic works well at a killing bacteria,
so if your sickness doesn't get any better by taking an antibiotic, either you're taking the raw
antibiotic or it's some crazy different bacteria that doesn't respond to that antibiotic,
or it's not a bacterial infection, it's something different, so just because you have all the
signs of acute lime doesn't mean it is a birellia bacterial infection, so how you can absolutely
know, or we're going to test for it, while those tests are very often false negatives,
you have to treat the person clinically, find a doctor that will do that, use his or her clinical
experience and make a decision based upon that, so seek that person out, and if you live in a chronic
lime area, or a high lime area, you should seek this kind of practitioner out before you're in a
crisis, you might even want to have antibiotics in your house before you're in a crisis, just think
about that, so seek medical care, this course is in no way a substitute for medical care, from a medical
legal standpoint, we have to say that, but I really truly believe that, you need to find
a medical practitioner that will work with you and can think other feet and make clinical decisions
based upon their years of experience and their desire to continue to learn, so this hopefully
this video will help with walking through that decision. Thanks so much, bye bye.